[Musique]
de l'Allemagne jusqu'au Canada
les appels pour améliorer la situation
des femmes et le respect des droits
humains en Iran résonnés
particulièrement fort ce samedi alors
que l'on soulignait le 75e anniversaire
de la déclaration du droit de la
personne le nom de ma famille dans la
mort à catalyser le soulèvement contre
le régime en septembre se mélanger cette
fois à un autre
de 23 ans a été pendu ce jeudi pour
avoir bloqué une vue et blessé un
paramilitaire en septembre c'est la
première exécution depuis le début du
soulèvement
des exécutions vont continuer les
politologues et organisations
humanitaires ont répertorié près d'une
quarantaine de manifestants condamnés à
mort qui pourrait très bientôt subir le
même sort une manière pour pour le
tairanien de donner un message fort
c'est d'en faire un exemple c'est
vraiment vous voyez la peine de mort et
ce type d'exécution sont un outil de
terreur d'intimidation et de menaces
c'est une arme usuelle du régime iranien
pour faire taire les dissidences selon
elles que certains individus vont avoir
vont avoir peur de sortir ne serait-ce
que sortir de chez eux parce que la
question c'est même pas de participer à
une manifestation il y a un sentiment
d'insécurité il y a un environnement
très lourd mais c'est un couteau à deux
tranchants l'ensemble du pays est
indigné parce que si vous voulez on est
en train de tuer les enfants d'un pays
avait 22 ans mais en scène à 23 ans on a
eu même des cas beaucoup plus jeune on a
eu Kian disons qui a perdu la vie ce
type de pratique
va contribuer à nourrir le sentiment de
frustration d'indignation de colère
ça ne nous fera pas tard ajoute cette
politologue iranienne elle pense qu'elle
indignation prendra le dessus sur la
peur pour bien d'autres comme elle